اعلن الناطق باسم كتاب القسام ابو عبيده
تمكن المقاومه خلال الاسبوع الماضي من
تدمير
8 اليه عسكريه كليا او جزئيا واكد اجهاز
كتاب القسام على
53 جنديا اسرائيليا من نقطه الصفر وقنص
تسعه جنود وايقاع العشرات بين قتيل وجريح
في 57 مهمه عسكريه مختلفه تم خلال هذه
المهمات استهداف القوات الاسرائيليه
بالقذائف والعبوات المضاده للتحصينات
والافراد والاسلحه الرشاشه كما اعلن ابو
عبيده قيام كتائب القسام بنسف اربعه منازل
وتفجير مدخلي انفاق وحقل الغام في جنود
العدو واسقاط طائرتي استطلاع من طراز
سكايلارك
والاستيلاء على ثمان مسيرات
واضاف ابو عبيده ان كتائب القسام دكت
الحشود العسكريه بقذائف الهاون والصواريخ
قصيره المدى في كافه المحاور محاور القتال
ووجهت رشقات صاروخيه بماديات مختلفه الى
داخل الكيان الصهيوني